hey calm down man
body camera video shows a suspect
pulling a weapon on police after
screaming that he refuses to go back to
prison it's in his hand it's in his hand
see he's moving it back and forth hey
it's in his right hand
fight it happened just after 10 a.m on
December 8th in Oklahoma City Oklahoma
that's where an off-duty police officer
is flagged down for a report of a man
with a gun as the off-duty cop calls for
backup the suspect later identified as
Reginald Davis fires a shot
multiple officers respond to the scene
including a crisis intervention team
body cam video shows officers attempting
to de-escalate the situation
hey calm down man
Davis can be heard yelling obscenities
at the officers and saying he won't go
back to prison
when Davis refuses to drop his weapon
officers fire a bean bag shotgun at him
bean bag bean bag bean bag after that
Davis grabs his pistol and points it at
officers four responding officers then
opened fire
after Davis is shot officers rushed to
find his weapon
I can't see him I can't see him watch
him watch him watch him I can't see him
is he from the doctor Davis was later
Taken to a nearby hospital and treated
for his injuries at one point he
attempted to run out of the hospital but
was tracked down by officers he was
arrested and booked into the Oklahoma
County Detention Center he now faces
multiple charges reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie